ما مدى خطورة هذه اللحظة على
البلد
أه شكرا لك كريستوفر وجودها في
غاية الخطورة أعتقد أن العراق لم يكن
لديه
هذا النوع من أه
مستوى العنف أو التهديد
بالعنف أه المرتبط
بعملية تشكيل الحكومة نعم
العراق أخذها دائما  الوقت أه لتشكيل
الحكومة بعد الانتخابات أه بسبب
التوزيع أه الديمغرافي
للسلطة وأيضاً أه القانون نفسه
وضوابط تشكيل
الحكومة التي كانت دائماً
أه سلمية وإه تم إه من خلال
التفاوض أه هذا  هي المرة الأولى التي
نشهد فيها جمود أه كاملاً
وأيضًا أه أه
تظاهرات مضادة
وأيضًا أه للأسف في
الساعات القليلة الماضية أه استخدام أسلحتنا
وأه أدى إلى وقوع إصابات أه
للأسف
كما أشرت حتى قبل هذه
الاحتجاجات القاتلة  لقد كان العراق في هذا
المأزق السياسي الذي تعرفه منذ
أن فاز حزب ساتورن بأكبر عدد من المقاعد
العام الماضي ولكن ليس بما يكفي للحكم
بالأغلبية فماذا؟  النظرة السياسية
للعراق للمضي قدمًا
هذا مرة أخرى أه نحن 11 شهرًا تقريبًا
في مرحلة ما بعد الانتخابات أه
عملية تشكيل الحكومة ومع
مرور الوقت أه في الأساس تزداد
المشكلة صعوبة وأصعب
حتى وإن فاز سوتر
ولكن فوزه  هو في الحقيقة بهامش ضئيل
حوالي 22 بالمائة من
العدد الكلي للمقاعد النيابية ما من
مكان قريب من الأغلبية أه لتشكيل
حكومة ناهيك عن
الثلثين المطلوبين لانتخاب
رئيس وإه يمضي أه برؤيته
الخاصة لحكومة هكذا
أه أنا لا أرى بأي حال من الأحوال أن
أه الرؤية التي يحاول
فرضها وهو ليس أه
أه يلين وهو تشكيل
حكومة أغلبية وطنية كما يسميها أه
ليست طائفية بل عبر
أه أسود طائفية عرقية  ما من سبيل
أه يمكن أه استيعابها
وبالتالي
أه النظرة أه من هذا
والسيناريو الوحيد الممكن
أن يقتنع كل الأطراف بأن أه الواقع
على الأرض سيمنع أه أيون  هـ
لفرض رؤيتهم الخاصة
لتشكيل الحكومة وسيتعين عليهم العودة
إلى التآزر والمفاوضات
وأخيراً الاتفاق ، الجزء المحزن هو
أنه كلما طال هذا الأمر ، كلما
استغرق هؤلاء الأشخاص وقتًا أطول لإدراك
هذه الحقيقة البسيطة أه زاد
للأسف أرواح
سنخسرها وكلما أه الوقت سيعيش العراقيون
في هذه
الظروف القلبية حيث
لا تلبي الحكومة احتياجاتهم.